this is Kurt and Davina speaking for
Alessandro filari the Resident Evil
three remake Styx very close to the
originals action-focused take on
survival horror while that's kind of
give you a greater feeling of control in
your struggle to survive the hordes of
undead it can often feel less scary than
other games in the series however once
you complete the story on hardcore
difficulty a new mode will open up which
feels closer to a survival horror
experience and presents Resident Evil 3
at its best in nightmare mode which is
essentially the very hard mode it
includes tougher enemies and less ammo
and reshuffles item locations those
changes are a lot to deal with as is but
it goes even further by remix encounters
with enemies along with more zombies to
deal with tougher monsters appear much
earlier and nemesis is far more
aggressive my nightmare mode play
through which rounded out to about four
hours offered a more worthwhile approach
to resin evil 3 survival horror that
actively placed more pressure on me as
it went on one of the reasons why
survival horror is so effective is that
actively creates an air of uncertainty
of not knowing what awaits around the
corner what I appreciated most about
nightmare mode is that it almost
immediately lets you know that things
aren't going to be the same this time
around this sentiment was exemplified
shortly after leaving the subway for the
first time I rushed into an alleyway
after taking out my first zombie and
almost ran head-on into a crowd of eight
undead looking for their next meal what
was a short encounter with a couple of
distracted zombies and other modes is
now a moment where your run can meet a
quick and violent end and it offered the
first of many rushes that I seldom felt
in my earlier playthroughs the
repositioning and reordering of enemies
not only makes for more claustrophobic
encounters but some areas now prompt
detours based on the increased danger
this reordering is especially evident
when nemesis comes into play in the
downtown area like mr. X from Resident
Evil to nemesis is a disruptor and just
when you feel you've got a handle of the
undead in the layout of the area the
villain makes a sudden entrance and
forces you on the run turning common
enemies and tight corridors into genuine
threats once again nightmare mode turns
this up
durably with the undead in higher
numbers and in some cases they will
block pathways when you're trying to
make a break from the unstoppable
bioweapon in addition to all these
changes to the gameplay nightmare mode
also adds bits of narrative that speak
more to the current emotional state of
the characters not seen in the standard
modes but in an interesting twist it
also shows off unseen events by far my
favorite moment in Resident Evil 3 is
revisiting the RPG station during the
sequence you get to see Brad's last
appearance in the game now as a zombie
and the default difficulties this
encounter ends in the courtyard with you
going about your business inside the
station but in nightmare mode the harder
difficulty gives Brad more time to shine
as he stalks you through the station on
more occasions and just like his
appearance in the original Resident Evil
2
Brad is one tough zombie and it'll take
more rounds than usual to take him down
in my 5 playthroughs of Resident Evil 3
remake I had the most fun with the game
in Nightmare as I mentioned my full
review
I felt that resin evil 3 struggled to
maintain the balance between survival
horror and action gameplay nightmare
mode however pushes the game further to
survival horror putting significant
pressure on you to pick your battles and
conserve ammo which is when survival
horror is at its best and if you're
still looking for more of a challenge
the game's final difficulty Inferno will
unlock after finishing nightmare mode
pushing the challenge even further even
with some of the bonus items and weapons
I managed to scrounge up after my first
run-through of the game nightmare mode
still presented a significant obstacle
to complete many encounters in this
difficulty are genuinely clever and it
makes me wonder why they weren't
included in a standard modes are usually
grown at taking on harder difficulties
but nightmare mode turned out to be a
pleasant surprise from a game I thought
I knew in and out and ended up
showcasing the remake at its finest
for more on Resident Evil 3 including
our review head over to GameSpot
you
[Music]